we are up to number 26 on the list of
the pft 2020
preseason power rankings and this is a
team that was tanking for tua
supposedly last september they didn't
tank and they still got tua anyway the
miami dolphins
you know finished strong down the
stretch rallied around coach brian
flores a lot of reason
for optimism yeah yeah i think that if
we'd have looked at this list mid to
late september last year we would have
laughed there's no way they're going to
be that high
going into 2020 but they gave us reason
to be somewhat optimistic chris how
optimistic are you big picture that this
dolphins team
is in the process of becoming a
contender the only team other than the
patriots to win the afc
east in the past 17 18 years right
yeah it's funny when you say it that way
you're like oh gosh well yeah that was a
more than a decade ago now but uh i'm
like
i'm i'm about as excited about a
roster turnover that i just saw with the
miami dolphins over the last year as i
can remember anytime here in just the
recent past
i mean hey what they've done in a year
is phenomenal i mean
they've changed our whole outlook you
kind of just said it i mean we kind of
went to a point of the year where we're
like i don't know if they're gonna ever
win a game
and then you know the last half of the
year they were competitive as
hell and then added to that with all the
moves they made last year
you know trading guys to get money off
their roster and off the
the salary cap and all that but then you
look at their additions this off season
and free agency
and the draft i mean you could really
argue the dolphins
won the off-season i i mean there's no
doubt about it
hey brian flores came from new england
what does new england do what are they
famous for right now
corner secondary one of the greatest
past defenses we've ever seen
oh well now he's got that going on down
there in miami
xavien howard then pays big money to to
byron jones
i mean that's going to be arguably one
of the best corner duos in all of
football
but then killing it in the draft with
the quarterback and good tackles
you know value signings you know with
guys like
uh shaq lawson and emmanuel agba that
yeah they're not gonna be superstars
mike but they're guys that we know will
fit that new england scheme so
i don't know i couldn't be more excited
about a new young tandem in all of
football than i am about the dolphins
with brian flores and chris greer i just
everything they've done so far i've gone
damn that's smart damn that makes sense
damn that fits your team
and that's why i am excited about them
going into the future here
hovering over all of this is the
quarterback question ryan fitzpatrick
tuatanga viloa no preseason to get two
already i wonder whether some of these
teams are going to
platoon their quarterbacks in september
and kind of treat it like
a preseason even though the games count
who knows how many games they'll get in
in september anyway
but there's a lingering sense around the
league that
tua ultimately was
an owner's pick and that happens from
time to time sure
that the owner gets involved and says
this is the guy i want the owner wanted
joe burrow there was nothing they could
do to get
joe burrow at least whatever they
offered the bengals wouldn't accept
for the trade from number five the
number one so they take tua because
steven ross wants a franchise
quarterback they haven't had a franchise
quarterback since dan marino yada yada
i still have concerns yeah me too about
tua from a health standpoint and i know
you have concerns beyond the health
standpoint you wonder
does that game translate to the nfl
level is he truly a high-end quarterback
or is it just benefiting from being in
the alabama system i think that's the
great unknown for this team he's going
to be on the field at some point he's
got to be on the field at some point
what are we going to see from it yeah no
you're right what are we going to see
from yeah there's a lot that i do like
you know and i know you know i was one
of those guys that you know during the
draft was certainly pushing back because
people were telling me two was the
greatest football player they've ever
seen and he's obviously the first pick
of the draft and all that
and that's where you know sometimes you
fight those narratives and he's
obviously a first-round pick i was never
trying to argue that
but yes i do want to see what tua is all
about
you know again i know he's got a lot of
great
you know natural things that he brings
as far as a quarterback he does have a
good arm it's not a great arm
it's a pretty quick release you know
he's got he's got quick feet in the
pocket he's not necessarily fast and all
that
but the one thing i will say over and
over again
you know is he plays small and of course
he was at alabama
now there's two things from alabama
there's a positive and negative one
i think adjustment to the nfl life like
we talked about with joe burrow will not
be that drastic he's been coached like a
pro
he's been in pro schemes and he's played
against and played with a lot of pro
players
so he'll be ready for that and then shan
gailey being the offensive coordinator
there
i think that fits to it too because it's
going to be a short quick
passing game galey's not famous for down
the field passing attacks like that
and that's one of the negatives i look
at it to it but you're right mike that's
to me
the big question i mean alabama's
offense didn't stall when tua
got hurt and was out for the rest of the
year last year you know so i want to see
is he capable of doing more
than what the system can deliver and to
me that's what a top 10 pick should do
and that's still a big question for me
21 of the last 30 first round
quarterbacks have started 10 or more
games their rookie seasons over under
tuatanga by lowa the starter by week
seven chris what do you got oh i'm
taking the under there
right i think it's going to happen
fairly early on in the year you know i
just think it's one of those things too
where if he shows he's healthy
and everything like that you know just
the owner the fan base
everybody's claiming i mean nobody
crapped on me in social media more
than the miami dolphins fans for where i
put tua and my quarterback rankings and
things like that they wouldn't give it
up i mean i was talking about top five
quarterbacks
and people were still tweeting about i
can't believe you put 240 or blah blah
blah so
i just think it's gonna be too much to
overcome and i think like we said with
saban alabama
you know that pedigree there already
he'll he'll be ready to go as far as nfl
is concerned
i think fitzpatrick starts week one but
you're right at some point before
week seven it's going to be touah
devante parker had a big year last year
202 receiving yards
he's plus 3 700 to lead the league
in receiving yards that's 100 it turns
into 3700
if he does take it the rest of the way
what's your over under let's use last
year 1202
yeah let's use 1202 are you going are
you going over you're going under oh
i'm gonna go i'm gonna go over i'm gonna
play this guy takes off this guy's a
superstar he just hasn't been able to
stay healthy and
this is the other point and i'm glad you
brought him up mike who else is on the
offense to feature anything around right
now you know that's where i just look
that's one of the issues i look at their
team right now is go
who other than him is going to make a
play on the offensive side of the ball
they got some solid
but no great running back and he's their
only great receiver
and i think they're going to feed him to
death so i'm going to go he stays
healthy and goes over 1200.
all right real quickly best case worst
case for the 2020 miami dolphins i think
best case is like you know they flirt
with 500
right around there you know i think
that's where i look at it you know not
not playoffs i don't think it's quite
there yet pain in the butt
certainly lose some close games but like
best case seven to nine eight and eight
worst case man they lose a lot of tough
football games and they end up like four
and 12 or five and 11.
yeah worst case they're in the mix for
trevor lawrence and then they really
have a decision to make
for 2021 that they could have him josh
rosen
and trevor lawrence they could have
three top ten picks on their roster
the guy that the cardinals dumped when
they went with tyler murray they could
do the same thing to tua next year if
they get in position for trevor lawrence
i don't think that's gonna happen i
think they're gonna be competitive
but i agree with you 500 or thereabouts
is the best they can hope for all right
let's take a break when we return
dalvin cook was supposed to hold out and
then he wasn't gonna hold out and then
he told the team he was gonna be there
and then his agent said i didn't tell
the team anything
tuesday came and went and dalvin cook
showed up
but what does it really mean between him
and the vikings we'll talk about that
when pft live continues right after this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports